there's an air of excitement in El
Salvador over Sunday's national election
and it's all because of this man
Salvadoran president naib
buele he's the self-described world's
coolest dictator who in five short years
has managed to transform El Salvador
from one of the most dangerous places in
the world into arguably the safest
country in Latin America today
Salvadorans like Gabi casades can walk
around freely in downtown San Salvador
without having to worry about being
robbed or falling victim to gang
violence I think the majority of
everybody would agree it's the security
uh to be honest it's not something that
I would come to the center of downtown
El salador I think that's one of the
things that we're really happy about
with ch security of course you know it
has taken some hard measurement to do it
those hard measures Gabby refers to
include the so-called state of
exception
which has been used to justify an
indefinite suspension of constitutional
rights and carry out a nationwide
Crackdown on
gangs it's a model that even other Latin
American leaders from countries where
insecurity is a problem have sought to
emulate a model that critics say
represents a threat to Salvadoran
democracy this so-called buelli model is
nothing more than Breaking with the
democratic system breaking with
constitutions breaking with fundamental
rights breaking with the International
Community and with the basic principles
of coexistence among countries in other
words it's a dictatorship like other
ones we've had in Latin America and
currently have albeit
disguised the argument from Human Rights
and civil liberties experts is that bu's
popularity is largely driven by a
willingness from Salvadorans to
sacrifice the country's democratic
values in the long term for the sake of
living in peace now Salvadoran voters
may have concerns over the future of
their country's democracy and the loss
of certain civil liberties but support
for president naiv buele and his
reelection is still overwhelming with
the presidential election just around
the corner naay bukele is all but sure
to win but as the accusations against
his government continue to mount the
question is how much longer this
overwhelming popularity can endure
Manuel rapo Al jazer s
Salvador make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer